MIKE O'BRIEN: Good
afternoon everybody.
My name is Mike O'Brien.
I'm with a company called
Appirio and I'm joined on stage
today by Adam Graff, from
Genentec, and Matt Pruden,
who is also from Appirio.
And we are thrilled that you've
joined us today for this Google
IO2010 enterprise session
called "Extending Google
Apps." And what we're
going to do in this session, is
we're going to go beyond
the typical Google apps.
Sort of an implementation of
migrating a customer off of
Exchange or migrating a
customer off of Lotus Notes,
and explore what it really
means to extend the platform.
Specifically, we're going
to look at three demos.
Three applications developed by
Appirio and by Genentech and
we're going to look
under the covers.
We're going to look at the
code, and the API that enabled
these apps to come together.
Also, we're going to look at
the business benefits that
Genentech is deriving as
a result of these apps.
Also we're going to a
look at a very cool new
Gmail gadget called
PS Connect recently
developed Appirio.
And, of course, we'll save some
time for Q&A at the end.
But before we get into all
these topics, we'd like to give
you a little bit of background
on of both Appirio and
Genentech; who we are, what
we're all about so you
kind of sense of how we
approach these topics.
So, let's start there.
Appirio was founed three and a
half, almost 4 years ago, with
a very singular focus of
helping customers move
through the cloud.
You can think of us as a cloud
solution provider whereby we
provide both products and
services to help customers
implement on Google on
SalesForce and on Amazon.
Then, when we started the
company, we said, hey, let's
not only do this for our
customers, but let's do
this for ourselves.
Today we're company of
over 200 employees.
We're in 28 different states.
We're in 3 different
countries and we don't
own a single server.
We own lots of laptops,
we even have some
Ipads, but no servers.
About 80% of infrastructure is
on the back of Google,
providing our a messaging and
collaboration layer and
Salesforce, providing our
application and platform layer.
Specifically, from a Google
perspective, we were fortunate
to become a Google Apps
Enterprise Partner
in May of 2007.
And, as such, we've had the
opportunity to work with
literally dozens and dozens of
medium and large enterprise
customers who have gone Google.
And, in fact, we've
participated in 6 of the 10
largest implementations
to date.
Those customers you see
here on this slide.
But, in addition to those
customers who have going
Google, we've also had the
opportunity to work with a
number of cutting edge, very
innovative customers like
Genentech who have truly
extended the platform.
Who have taken advantage of
incredibly rich and robust
API's that Google has made
available and have customized
Google apps in a way that
better conforms to their
business processes.
So, to those points I'd
like to invite Adam and
Matt to jump in here.
Adam to provide a bit of
background on Genentech and
to share with us these
very cool demos.
ADAM GRAFF: Thanks Mike.
Good afternoon, everyone.
My name is Adam Graff, and I
manage a very talented team of
software developers and
engineers at Genentech who are
focused on collaboration tools
and mobile applications
within our enterprise.
And, so, just to give you an
idea of who Genentech is,
in case you don't know.
Genentech was founded in 1976
by Herb Boyer and Bob Swanson
as the first biotechnology
company in the world.
Over the years, since our
founding, we've had a
lot of great successes.
From our first cloned human
growth hormone drug to the
latest blockbusters which deal
in the onocology space of
Avastin, Rituxin,
and Herceptin.
So, oftentimes people ask me or
ask Genentech employees what
motivate you guys to get up
in the morning go to work?
And the main thing that
motivates us as the company and
as a whole and I think you
could ask Genentech employee
this question, it's
the patients.
So focusing in on making sure
that we are always identifying
how our work ties into the
quality of products that we're
delivering and the lives that
we're saving through our drugs.
So, how does that relate IT?
IT embraces this in many ways.
And the service that we provide
to our end users is an enabling
and academic computing
environment.
So what this means, is we give
as much room as we can to our
users to be able to choose the
platform they want to be on.
To choose the tools that they
want to work with, and most
importantly, give back as much
time as we possibly can,
through IT and not make things
more complicated than
they should be.
So, just to give you an idea of
our environment, to paint a
story for you, we've got about
40% of our users on Macs.
We have about 60% of
our users on PC's.
We got Iphones, we've got
blackberries, we've got a
handful of Androids out there,
so it's of it's a pretty mixed
environment that we
have to support.
And so, we do whatever it
takes, basically, to support
scientific innovation.
So, putting that into
perspective, to give you an
idea of where we are with
Google Apps and kind of where
we've come from over the
last year and a half.
Back in 2008, we realized that
we had the big problem on our
hands to deal with in our email
infrastructure and calendaring
infrastructure, so we started
looking at different vendors
and the space to figure out
what we're going to do
to fix the problem.
And, of course, since we had
such a wide variety of
platforms we have to support,
whatever we implemented had to
be able to support that.
And, that's where Google
came into the picture.
By enabling us to go to the
web, it got us out of the space
of having to have thick clients
that were dedicated to Windows
or Apple Mail or Outlook
and so on and so forth.
And so, once we came on board
with Google initially with
Google Calendar first.
We got through that.
Migrated off of our existing
system into the cloud, and
currently were actually
implementing Gmail.
So, we're migrating about
17,000 users over the course
of the next 6 months
to the platform.
So, one of the great things
that we realized once we
started using Google, is
that you can think it as a
platform to be extended.
It's something bigger than just
the products themselves so when
we started to think about this
and spent some time with it to
figure out OK what can we do in
terms of developing small tools
that enable our users to do
unique things; integrate
between legacy applications, so
for example, keep people in one
user interface, Gmail, for
example, instead of having to
flip around between different
applications to get
the information that
they're looking for.
So, with Appirio, one of
the first projects that we
looked at was this, gLinda.
And, gLinda is a g-talk
bot, so as soon as
Google released XMPP support,
an app engine, we immediately
glommed on to that.
We'd had this idea in the back
of our heads for a while.
So, it's a g-talk bot, that
basically lives in the Gmail
interface and from a very high
level, answers questions.
So, let me paint a
picture for you.
I'm sitting at my desk writing
an email message and I realized
in the middle of that email
message this is way too
complex, I don't want to send
an email, I actually want
to call the person.
So what you would normally do
as an end user, is open up a
new browser or a tab, go to the
coporate directory, look up
that person's information, and
pick up the phone and call.
With gLinda, we can actually
ask her who is John Doe?
And, she will answer back with
that contact information that
comes from our corporate
directory right in g-talk so
you no longer have to
leave Gmail to go find
that information.
And that's what we tried to do
with all of these different
questions that we've
set her up to answer.
So you can search for
information that integrates
with our Google search
appliance infrastructure that's
internal to Genentech as
well as Google Search.
You can ask "WhoIs"
of course to get the corporate
directory information.
You can ask "WhereIs"
and that integrates with Google
Calendar to reply back what
meeting that person may
be in at that time.
And then just for fun, we
can run a Magic 8 ball
question for our users.
So, I'll turn it over to Matt
now and he'll tell you kind
of what is on the back end
to enable us to do this.
MATT PRUDEN: Thanks, Adam.
Ok, so lets actually flip over
here and talk to gLinda.
Hello, gLinda.
Obviously, gLinda's going out.
She's going to respond to us.
We can ask her questions.
I'm not sure where I
am right now, so lets
just check on me here.
Where is Matthew here?
And gLinda is going to go out
and look at my Google calendar.
It's gonna said, well,
I'm in a meeting.
I'm giving a demo of Google IO.
So, okay, well, what is this
Google IO thing? gLinda is
going to go out and search.
It's going to say, well, Google
IO, according to Google if I
click link, it will
tell me all about.
So, that's a real simple demo
of how this works and the
whole idea here is that
this is supposed to be fun.
Right, it's supposed be
interesting and catch on
so let's just try one
more thing on here.
Let's try the Magic 8.
Lets pick on Mike here.
Will mike's demo that
he's gonna give here
in a minute succeed?
Yes, good job Mike.
That bribe worked.
So, let's go behind the scenes
and see how this thing works.
OK,obviously , we know
this is an App engine.
Adam said this earlier.
But, did we have to go out look
at 10 different XMPP libraries?
No.
Did we have to go to some
enterprise architectural review
board and get them to buy and
say yes, this passes our
security audits, and all that?
No, we didn't have
to do any of that.
And that's because there's
already a great high-level
extraction to do XMPP right
out of the box in app engine.
And here's some example
code that it shows
just how easy this is.
There's really 3 things
to keep in mind here.
First, we're just loading in a
standard Python module here.
We're extending a class,
Command Handler, in this case.
We're going in, we're
overriding an existing function
called "Unhandled"
command and this runs any time
we just type jiberish
in, this will respond.
And, if we type something that
really matters, we'll run this
method called, "Text
Message" and in here, if
you've written some Python,
you'll notice this is kind of
standard Python stuff here.
We've got a familiar dispatch
pattern there in the text
message method that will go out
and run the Magic 8 function if
that's what it calls for.
I guess I should have added
the bride code in there.
We've got some decorators here.
We have the oft-required
decorator.
This is just something we
wrote and let me talk
about that a minute.
We obviously want gLinda to
respond to humans, right?
We don't want gLinda responding
to people she shouldn't
be responding to.
People that are in trying
to get information.
So, because of this very nice
extraction app engine provides,
we're able to do n number of
validation checks on the
sender the message.
So we can go and check,
perhaps, are they a member
of our Google aps domain?
Do they exist in our
corporate directory?
There are a bunch of
things we can do.
In this case, we do a
lot of those checks.
We also go and we use other
services of app engine to
actually send an email to that
user, make sure that they
receive email, click a link.
We record that on
the data store.
We check that on every request.
These are things that you can
do to just validate that the
user is someone that should
be receiving these messages.
Another thing I want to point
out that app engine gives us is
the whole idea here is we want
this to spread virally, right?
We want to be fun.
The downside to doing that, is
there's a good chance we're
going to go from 100 requests
a day to around 10,000.
And when we do that it's good
to know that app engine is
behind the scenes and can
dynamically scale and support
that kind of load and to get us
those 10,000 users, Adam's
going to come back and talk
about an application that helps
people get started
using Google apps.
ADAM GRAFF: Ok, so I mentioned
earlier that we were in the
middle of our migration of
users to Gmail At Genentech,
another the great thing about
working there is that we do
provide a very high level of
support to our end users and
for our Gmail migration,
it's no different.
We decided to form a group of
people who are dedicated to
providing one-on-one support.
You can call them up.
You can schedule them
to come to your desk.
You can schedule
group training.
You can schedule web-ex
sessions, however you want to
get support for you as you're
going through the
migration period.
We're available to help.
And so, when we formed this
group, we realized early on
that one of the challenges that
we had, was how do we manage
all of these appointments that
are going to be coming in from
the 17,000 people that are
going to be migrating over?
So, at that point, we had a
choice that we could make.
We could either hire a
coordinator that managed 8
people schedules and scheduling
all of the meetings in Google
calendar, or we could approach
this problem from a technical
perspective and see if we could
find a technical solution.
And that's exactly what we did
with Appirio and the Google
apps Concierge tool.
So, the Google apps Concierge
tool from, again, a very high
level takes x numbers of
calendars for individual people
and then aggregates it down
into one view that's presented
to the end user that you
can then book a time with
one of the concerieges.
Then on the concierge side, it
books the time automatically in
whoever's calendar is free for
that time slot and then
notified them of the
upcoming appointment.
This has been a great tool for
us because it gives our end
users the ability to control
when they want to receive
support it very easy for them
and gives that gives them
the opportunity to get the
support that they need.
So, I'll turn it over to Matt
again to look at the back end.
MATT PRUDEN: Let's see if I can
shrink this down a little bit.
Ok, so this is the application.
You'll see this looks very much
like a very simple web app.
It modern.
It has the rounded corners,
and all the things
you would expect.
The idea here is that this
should be extremely simple;
kind of one click.
Get access to a concierge, book
your appointment, get the help
you need and get on
with your day job.
I'm not spend a lot of time
walking through this just
cuz there's not much to it.
You click a button, you
type in your information
and you're done.
So let me go back to the slides
and show how this works.
As you can tell by the image
here this is app engine again
except this time it's
the Java Runtime.
And, specifically here's some
code from there, and I was
going to ask the audience here,
what's interesting about it?
And looking at that, I think
the answer is, there's nothing
interesting about that code.
Nothing at all.
I think oftentimes we overlook
the fact a conference like this
or when we're getting blasted
with all this new technology
that if we have skills that
we've acquired or master over
10 or 15 years like doing
HTML and JSP pages.
We don't have to learn
a lot of new stuff.
We can take that and
immediately began
and start using it.
And that's exactly
what we had here.
We had experience designers.
We have people that are
used to looking at these
tags in their HTML.
We have people that knew JSP,
and they could begin and use
those skills on app engine,
without having to learn Glib.
Although would probably been
a lot more interesting.
Another thing to point out here
is, they didn't even learn a
lot of data source stuff
for this application.
And the reason is because,
Genentech, like a lot of
enterprises, has invested in
their enterprise service plus
infrastructure and we were
able to just reuse that
investment from App Engine.
Here we are using the same
java classes that people are
familiar with to do HTPP
communication and that's
exactly what we're doing here.
We're getting JSON on
back from their ESP.
That actually would
be interesting talk
in and of itself.
It talks out to Google Calendar
and a lot of other systems in
order to check calendar
availability and book
calendar appointments.
That's all there is to it.
I think that the whole point
here is that although as
developers, we all wish we
could learn new stuff every
day, a lot of times
it's not realistic.
It's not the right thing to do.
So, if you already have those
skills that you've learned
over 15 years, feel free to
bring to bear in AppEngine.
Adam.
ADAM GRAFF: OK, so just
extrapolate a little further on
Matt's comment around our
investment in our enterprise
service bus architecture, so in
general, when we are
implementing on the Google
platform, we do try and
implement or tie into Google's
API's with our enterprise
service bus and then expose
those as web services.
And that gives us a couple of
advantages from a couple of
different perspectives,
because then we can
reuse those services.
So, some of the same services
that we developed for
gLinda were reused in the
concierge app as well.
And we're seeing that
throughout the enterprises as
both recognition of the
platform's capabilities grow
and then as people are starting
to pick up and do more
implementations on it.
So this next the integration is
one of the more interesting
ones that we've done over the
course of the last year for a
couple of different reasons.
So I mentioned earlier that one
of the goals of our team is to
give time back to our employees
to make sure that they're
focused on the work that
they're there to do and
make their jobs easier.
So, at Genentech, we
obviously use Google Apps.
we also sales force.com so
we've got 2 major pieces of our
infrastructure in the cloud.
And one of the pieces of
feedback that we got from are
sales force, our commercial
organization, was that
they're having to manage
too many calendars.
So, day in the life of, if I'm
a sales person, I've got to
wake up in the morning, look at
my personal Google calendar,
check my meetings and
appointments there with
my colleagues at work.
Then you've got team calendars
in addition to that, that have
all kinds of events that
the people are managing so
you've gotta check that.
And then you got to switch over
again to Salesforce.com and
then look at your Salesforce
calendar and figure out, what
are my appointments with
doctors and with health care
professionals and so
on and so forth.
So, our sales folks are
managing 3 possibly even the up
to 10 different calendars to
figure out what they needed
to do in their day.
So, big problem.
With the unified calendar, what
we were able to do was, because
of the open standards and open
nature of both Salesforce and
Google is take Salesforce, the
calendar in Salesforce and
bring it in and funnel it down
into one view in
Google Calendar.
So now our sales force
team has one place to go.
All of their appointments show
in one screen and then they
also have the ability to manage
their events and subscribe to
events that they're interested
in, like educational series
about new drugs or new ways to
present information to doctors
based on FDA regulations
and so on and so forth.
So, I'll hand it
back to Matt again.
MATT PRUDEN: As you
might guess, now
going to give a demo!
Like Adam said, this is a very
big application and we could
easily spend 8 hours going into
the nuts and bolts of how this
whole thing works and anyone
that's done calendar
syncronization knows
what I'm talking about.
So what I'm going to focus on
today is just one part of this
and the piece that I think that
most applies to the audience
here and that is this Google
gadget over here on the right.
In order to kind of explain
what we should be looking at
here, let me talk a little
bit about the business case.
As a user of Google Calendar,
here I'm going to have a lot
of appointments every day.
Some of these are
personal appointments.
Some of them are meetings
people have booked with me but
others live in Salesforce.
The system of record of those
lives in Salesforce and those
are behind the scenes
synchronized and they show up
on my calendar and these are
what we call interactions.
An interaction, in this case,
is just a meeting with someone
in the medical industry about a
Genentech product or
a Genentech event or
something like that.
So, we have a couple
of those here.
You see I've got one at
noon today, or I had
one at noon today.
I've got another one at
5:00 today and these
are calls with people.
And once again, these
live in Salesforce.
This is where they were created
and then magically, they were
pushed through the enterprise
service bus right
here to my calendar.
So, what we have is this gadget
and what it does is it shows
all of the interactions, all
those special events that are
on my calendar that are
visible right now.
You can see there's 2,
so there's 2 showing
up right here.
Let me go to just go to the
week view so now I'm seeing
more my calendar and the
interaction that load up up and
now I'm looking at it 3
difference interactions because
I can see 3; the 2 that are
today and the 1 at 1:00 p.m.
Tomorrow.
So when I use this gadget, the
idea is that I can click
directly from my Google
calendar and go back to sales
force to look at interesting
things about the interaction.
I can look at the account,
I can look at the
interaction itself.
I'm not going to go
through that right now.
I'm just going to
focus on the gadget.
The other thing you'll
notice is I have a second
calendar over here called
commercial events.
And these are events that I
personally find interesting.
I go into Salesforce, I select
a bunch of criteria, things
that are interesting to me, and
then out a potentially
thousands of events, Salesforce
will figure out the events that
interest me and it'll push them
to this special calendar
that's unique to me.
And whenever this calendar is
visible, I have a link at the
bottom of the gadget that
says, edit my commercial
event preferences.
This is where I would go and
say, OK, now I'm only
interested in events related
to this particular product,
or that product or
something like that.
One thing that I want to point
out that's important when
you're designing a gadget, is
that there's limited screen
real estate here, so if I'm not
viewing that calendar if you'll
pay attention to the gadget
when I de-select that
hopefully, the gadget should
respond and hide that.
Exactly like it's not doing!
So, imagine a nice fade
of that disappearing.
Let's try that again.
00:24:21,8 --> 00:24:21,22
Ah, there we go.
And that's something to keep
in mind when you're writing
gadgets, is respect the
user's screen real estate.
There's not a lot there.
They may have other gadgets.
If you're hogging all the
space, they're going to
get rid of your gadget,
so keep that in mind.
OK, let me switch
over to some code.
Before I show the code
though,let me just emphasize
this is kind of a merger of
equals, this application here.
It's kind of equal parts Sales
force being the system of
record, equal part Google being
the user interface and then
equal part all the glue that
makes it works, and thats
the enterprise service bus.
The first little code snippette
that I want to talk about is
really what orchestrates the
entire gadget and this is the
standard kind of calendar
sidebar API that you use.
This is all Javascript.
And what we're doing here is
any time the user changes the
visible number of events they
are seeing, if they're looking
at day and they go to the
week view like I did, then
this subscribe to dates
function's going to run.
It's going a call back.
In this case, got dates, and
this starts the gadget.
So, now we have the dates.
Now we need go and ask Google
to get us all the events
for that date range.
And this is an important
pattern you'll see.
It's not is well-documented as
I think it should be, but it's
something that it once you get
the hang of it, it really
makes writing gadgets easier.
And that is always assume that
the user isn't authorize.
So we're going to go we're
going to ask Google, hey
give me a bunch of events.
Most people would say, well
before we do that, we need to
authorize the user to make
sure they have access
to these events.
But it turns out that's
actually not the best way
to do it because we're
using 3 [? leg go ?]
auth here, and the user could
revoke the token at any time,
and we're not guaranteed this
is going to succeed so let's
just go ahead and try
to get it anyway.
And if you haven't seen code
like this, asynchronous
Javascript like this, the way
to read it is to just
start at the bottom.
We're going to ask the
calendar, to give
us all the events.
That's either going to succeed
or it's going to fail.
If it succeeds, great.
We got the events.
Run the display event function
or method right here.
If it failed, and it failed
because we weren't authorized
to run this fictious method
here that I put in just to make
it so there's less code on the
screen here then authorize me
and this would do the normal
OAuth dance and ask which
account do you want to use to
authorize and all that stuff.
This code actually uses the
Shindig library from Apache
to automate all this stuff.
It's really clean.
And after we do that, then we
just call the same method again
and this kind of very simple
recursion makes authorization
with OAuth very, very easy.
OK, so now we've got events,
we're authorized, excuse me,
we've got an event feed from
Google were authorized.
Now, let's display the
events on the screen.
To do that, we need to identify
out of potentially hundreds of
events that were returned,
which ones are interactions?
And sure, we could do that by
looking at the subject and
trying to say well, if the
subject looks this way, then
it's probably an event that was
pushed from Salesforce, but the
user could always change the
subject and that would lead to
a bug down the road so that's
not the right thing to do.
So, instead, we use something
that's often overlooked.
And, it's extended properties.
And this is a standard
feature of the calendar API.
Any event can have arbitrary
name value pairs attached to it
and that's what we do here.
So whenever Salesforce, through
the ESB, creates these
events, we add a bunch of
extended property to it.
The user has no idea
those are there.
They can't change them, but we,
the programmer can, and we can
look at them so that's
what we do here.
We just loop through
every event in the feed.
If it has certain extended
properties, then we know
it came from Salesforce.
We know it's an interaction.
We know we should display
it in the gadget.
So, with that I'm going to
hand it back to Mike and
he's gonna talk more
about some gadget work.
Thank you Matt.
Thank you Adam.
Lets hope that the the Magic 8
Ball predicted accurately and
this last demo works smoothly.
We'll find out.
Imagine, if you will, what it
would be like to run your
entire business in the cloud.
Gartner tells us that 1 out
of 5 companies, 20% of the
companies are going to do this.
They're going to be
server-less by the year 2012.
Appirio doesn't only do this
for our customers, we actually
do it for ourselves.
That's how we run our business
and now with Gmail contentual
gadgets and a new product from
Appirio called PS Connect, you
can do all of that directly
within Google Apps.
Let me show you how.
So for this demo, let's assume
I run our services organization
and do so, I need a lot of
powerful enterprise
applications.
I need to be able to manage
my people, my projects, my
customers, my financials.
And to do so, I need a
lot of powerful apps.
I use apps all the cloud.
I use Salesforce.com to manage
my leads and my opportunities.
I use a force.com application
called PS Enterprise to manage
my projects and my resources.
So you can see I've got
a lot of information
out there, right?
That's all necessary to run my
business, but unfortunately
this isn't where
I spend my day.
This is.
This is where I make dozens and
dozens of decisions throughout
the day that affect my
operations, but I do so without
the benefit of all that
information thats locked
up in the cloud.
But now, with Gmail contextual
gadgets and PS Connect, I
can do that within my email.
Let me show you how I do that.
So when I start my day, I
typically will zero in on
customer related emails.
Here's one from Carl Customer.
This one looks like Carl
wants to go to lunch.
Well I'm not typical going
to prioritize this.
It doesn't seem very urgent.
Certainly I'm not to go out to
my CRM System and see what kind
of projects and opportunities
we have open with this
particular customer.
But, you know what?
That would be a mistake,
because look down here.
At the bottom of this email, is
a new Gmail contextual gadget
called PS Connect that's
gone out to my enterprise
applications and gathered all
the relevent information and
displayed it to me here.
So, of course, I've got
contact information and such.
But look.
I've got 7 opportunities in
my CRM system open with
this particular customer.
One of them here happens
to be related to this
particular email.
It's the office relocation
which happens to be on
hold, but guess what?
I just learned from this
particular email that the
New York office move is
complete, so I can now
take action directly
from within this email.
I can change the stage from
prospecting to qualified and
that automatically
gets updated.
I can add this record to my CRM
system so the entire account
team can see what's going on.
And, I typically wouldn't have
done either of those two things
until the night before the
sales call, but because I've
now done them, and I've
informed my sales team what's
going on, I can go ahead and
appropriately response to this
customer and say sounds great.
Looking forward to
lunch next week.
So far, so good.
So I'm going back to my inbox
and look at the next email.
Izzy Impatience.
This is from a customer that
doesn't look to be too happy.
It looks like his
project is off track.
Now, typically this would
just set off a flurry of
activity in my company.
Who's project is this?
What's the status?
What are we doing about it?
One big fire drill, right?
You know what?
All of this information
is probably within my
PS Enterprise system.
And PS Connect has brought that
information back to me here.
So I can see this customer
happens to have 3 projects
open. 2 of them are
in green status.
One of them happens
to be in red.
That's probably the one
he's talking about here.
Implementation.
I see a note from the project
manager that says the
schedule will slip unless an
architect is extended.
So you know what?
I'm familiar enough with my
project, with the staffing
situation, that I can go ahead
and an extended resource.
00:32:38,298 --> 00:32:38,14
But you know what?
Is that a smart thing to do?
Additionally, I have more
information here that
says this project has
plenty of budget left.
I've got over $600,000
so you know what?
I'm going to go ahead and
inform my staffing team that
we're extending this resource
and I'm going to respond to
Scott to say, hey the resource
has been extended, and
he's going to be thrilled.
So, you can see by running your
entire business in the cloud,
it's a vastly different
experience, right?
You have the ability to go out
to your enterprise systems
aggregate all that information
and directly within Google Apps
again thanks to Gmail
contextual gadgets
and PS Connect.
Ok, so that is the
end of our demos.
I'm going to transition
back over to here and
open up to Q&A.
We obviously talked about 3
gadgets, three demos that we
developed Genentech and the
one here developed by Appirio
and we want to open up to
questions for any of those.
There must be some questions.
Come on, you can ask
some tough ones!
There are developers and
engineers in the room from both
Appirio and Genentech who have
worked on some of
these projects.
If you would just step up
to the microphone so that
everyone can hear you?
AUDIENCE: So, what's next?
What do you have in mind as
far as the next enterprise
applications that you could
build on top of Google Apps,
using the API's and utilize
within Genentech or Appirio?
MATT PRUDEN: Yeah,
great questions.
We see tons of opportunities
to continue to move
functionality to the cloud.
Google continues to offer
richer and richer API's
that makes that possible.
You know anything that you see
happening behind the firewall
today, whether it's single sign
on or directory service as
examples, those are things that
could be taken out to the cloud
and become part of not your
network behind the firewall but
your network in the cloud and
we see Google continuing to
make advances in those areas to
make things like that possible.
ADAM GRAFF: Mike and
I can actually add a
little bit to that.
Some of what Genentech is
looking at as well so I
mentioned trying to keep
people as Mike has
talked about as well.
Try to keep people in one
interface, on there's a lot of
benefit there, so looking at
the contextual gadgets, there's
a lot of opportunity in that
area specifically to integrate
with some of the legacy
systems that we have.
So, for example, you look
at SAP and you get email
notifications for invoice
approvals or for payment
processing, whatever it is,
there's a lot of opportunity
there to keep people from
having to jump over to SAP log
in, do the transaction and then
come back to the email message.
You could actually
implement that within the
contextual gadget too.
So, this something that we
are thinking about to.
AUDIENCE: Ok, guys,
thanks for your time.
Two-part question: How do
you see these approach is
integrating with other
social and collaberation
portals like Wave?
And also, how do you see
them fitting in with
other enterprise portal
framework like Liferay?
MATT PRUDEN: I'm sorry.
I
missed the second question.
AUDIENCE: How do you see these
kinds of integration approaches
working with other enterprise
portal frameworks like Liferay,
or Oracle Portal, or
Sharepoint, or pick a flavor.
Is there an integration path?
Is there any
strategy behind it?
Has anyone thought in
that direction yet?
MIKE O'BRIEN: I guess I can
answer the second part
of question generally.
I'm not familiar with a lot of
those products, but what we
have tried to do at Genentech
as well and really everywhere,
is push the open standard,
so use open ID, use
three-legged OAuth.
use these things and then
hopefully all the vendors that
typically do things in a
proprietary fashion are going
to gradually trend in more of a
standards way and the
investments we make in
the standards will
continue to work.
AUDIENCE: Could you just
extend that statement?
Would you consider Portlet
standards like GSR-T68 as
being part of that family
or not part of that family?
MIKE O'BRIEN: I'm not familiar
enough with it to answer that,
but it sounds like
its a standard.
MATT PRUDEN: I'll try to answer
the first part of that,
regarding Wave, obviously we've
all been using Wave
for the last year.
We've used it in the consultant
environment with a number of
customers and were aware that
it was coming to Google Apps
obviously for some time now.
Thrilled with the
announcement this morning.
And we're looking forward
using it out the field.
Project based sort of
collaberative communication
work is where we've seen
that the best usage of it.
In terms of expanding upon that
it's still early stage, but
certainly we'll see
opportunities there.
00:37:40,338 --> 00:37:40,138
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Genentech, how do you
feel that Google's meeting your
compliance needs with respect
to HIPAA and GMP for the
software you have to develop?
Do they make your compliance
people happy with the security
they provided and the
software testing and so on?
ADAM GRAFF: In general yes.
Within Genentech there's a
pretty distinct line drawn
between the validated world, so
to speak, GNP, GCP, GLP -- for
those of you that don't know in
the audience, this is like FDA
regulations speak for systems
that have to deal with drug
manufacturing --so there's a
very distinct line that's
drawn between the two.
We have gone through a
particular exercise with one of
our integrations between SAP
and Google and have had pretty
good success with that
particular instance in getting
qualities buy off on the
security model the data
center security as well.
I think there's some
opportunity there.
It a little more difficult just
because of the nature of what
you're dealing with in the
regulated environment.
But, yeah they seem generally
pretty pleased as long as we
don't cross the line too much.
AUDIENCE: Ok, Thanks.
MATT PRUDEN: Any
other questions?
AUDIENCE: You were obviously
using something before Google
Apps, so what was that, and
what were the challenges in
moving the users from where you
were to over the Google Apps?
What kinds of things
should we look out for?
ADAM GRAFF: Sure.
Good question.
So before using Google Apps, we
were using Oracle Calendar for
our calendaring system and the
reason we were using Oracle
Calendar, like I said before,
is because we needed that broad
platform support in
supporting both Macs and PCs
and mobile devices.
And then for our email
solution, we were, and still
are, for some people that
haven't migrated yet using
SendMail as the infrastructure.
So the migration from Oracle
Calendar to Google Calendar was
a cut over events so we did it
with Appirio actually over a
weekend, migrated every data.
They got to work on Monday
morning and they were
on Google Calendar.
That was a largely successful,
extremely successful
implementation that in many
ways kind of set the standard
for how Google apps migrations
have gone forward after that.
Our email migration, just
because of the complexity that
we have, we don't limit our
users mailboxes sizes at
Genentech so we have a lot of
people with a lot of
large mailboxes.
Some people have been there for
30 years, so on and so forth.
So that that's a little more
complex because of the amount
of data that we're dealing
with, so we have to migrate
them in a different way.
Its not a cutover event, its a
800 people every other week
kind of thing and actually
going very well for us so far.
AUDIENCE: Can
you comment a little bit
more about your PS Connect?
Is it something like Gmail?
And you can see the
advertising?Is it
related to your mail?
Something like that?
I mean how does
PS Connect work?
MATT PRUDEN: So, PS Connect is
a Gmail contextual gadget that
uses a force.com application at
the back end integrated behind
the scenes called PSEnterprise
and it's extracting data out of
this force.com application and
displaying it in an intelligent
way based on the sender of
email, the receiver of the
email, or the content
of the email.
AUDIENCE: You searched
every word of the content?
Yes.
Any other questions?
AUDIENCE: Now you have
integrating this ESP and Google
app, and is that a big problem
or how's infrastructure
behind that?
MIKE O'BRIEN: It's actually
extreme simple, so the
infrastructure from Google,
from my perspective it's let's
say if I was programming an app
engine it's very simple I can
just send an HTTP request to a
URL and its give me JSON
or whatever I want.
Give me XML and then I
just consume that like I
would any data source.
So, from that perspective
it's very simple.
Its obviously a little bit more
complex behind the scenes.
A lot of that calendar I would
suspect, although i didn't
write this code but a lot of
the calendar API interaction
that's happening in the ESP is
it's probably extracting a lot
of Gdata, calendar
calls, right?
Getting event feeds searching
and those feeds and doing those
kinds of things and that's
done in java in the
enterprise service bus.
AUDIENCE: OK, Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Hi, hey, thanks
again for the presentation.
I really appreciate that.
I notice in most the client
examples that you gave were all
through the web interface using
the Gmail interface and I was
curious if you allow users to
use, say, a desktop client
of their preference?
Say maybe have users who
like Microsoft Outlook
or Apple mail?
And if you do, I'm curious to
see if that if that works?
How well thats work for you?
ADAM GRAFF: Sure,
good question.
So the strategy that we are
employing for our deployment
is to move people to the
web interface first.
We have done some pretty
in-depth analysis on of what
are the issues that people
run into with email?
Is the problems with the
clients, the thick client?
back end mail serve?
And so on and so forth.
So, what we found is that based
on a pilot we ran for about a
year, we find that people end
up after they get over the
initial hump of adjusting to
the web interface and go
through the change, get the
right training, get the right
support, they end up having
fewer problems than the web
interface than what they had in
the Outlook or Apple Mail
interface, so we do allow
people to make the choice
for the most part.
We go first to the Web UI, than
if you just you can't live in
it, or have a business reason
for needing the Apple Mail, or
Outlook client, we'll
give it to you.
We're not going to restrict you
but, we do encourage people
to go that way first.
And we trained to that, and
provide a change management
support for that as well.
AUDIENCE: Hi, you mentioned
real estate as being a concern
in the gmail interface.
Do you have any provision in
place for changes that Google
might make to the interface,
and is there anyway ahead of
time where your box might
get eliminated by new box?
MIKE O'BRIEN: That's a
really good question.
So one of the benefits of
using Google Apps, it's
always changing, right?
It seems like features come out
every day and certainly Google
could release a feature that
could impact a particular user
interface that we're going for.
But the good thing is that
these things happen slowly so
usually it's not as if the
entire sidebar is going
to go away one day.
They go away if they were to
do that, in my experience,
they would communicate
a change of that size.
And, I'm interested in your
perspective on this, Adam.
I think enterprises are
probably a bit scared of
that kind of rapid pace of
innovation when they start.
But, I really think users or
are familiar with it, because
so many people use
Gmail every day.
This kind of thing doesn't
really bother people I think.
And, I think that as users
begin using Google Apps, in the
enterprise, these small changes
they'll see as good
things, right?
Not, as oh my gosh you're
breaking something.
Is that kind of what you seen?
ADAM GRAFF: Yeah, absolutely.
In the beginning when we first
moved from Oracle Calendar to
Google Calendar, there was a
shock period for people
especially whenever new changes
would come up, we'd get tons of
calls to our service desk
asking what is this?
How do I use it, in and
so on and so forth.
And, what we've seen over time
is that people gradually adjust
they go back to that to that
mentality, oh yea is just
gmail, its just Google calendar
and this is kind of the
way things work with it.
AUDIENCE: This is for
Genentech question.
You mentioned primary data
associated with corporate
information like user
accounts and so forth.
[? Inpharma ?]
is a big componant
of scientific data.
Do you perceive issues related
to migrating some of the
scientific information
particularly computation aspect
running on the app engine?
Have you seen any requests
from that space?
ADAM GRAFF: So no,
not necessarily.
We don't really see a
security risk in having
that data hosted.
Is that the question
you're asking?
AUDIENCE: That's one aspect.
Also, its a regulated
environment, as you know.
ADAM GRAFF: We don't really see
a risk in migrating data out.
Scientific research data,
things of that sort, the
security that google apps is
able to provide for the most
part at least meets, and in
many places exceeds the
security that we're able
to provide in terms of
how it's implemented.
AUDIENCE: I was more like
concerned about the
lawyers aspect.
ADAM GRAFF: Oh, the
lawyers aspect, yes.
It did take some work to get to
the point where our lawyers
were comfortable with us
storing information
in the cloud.
I think I showed the slide of
the timeline where we spent
time evaluating what
the platform was.
I'd say about 90% of that
time was time with lawyers
getting them familiar.
Having them converse with the
Google's lawyers to understand
exactly what the use cases or
what the possibilities are and
then for the most part there's
only one particular area where
we found a gap, and it has to
do with data privacy protection
laws when you get into a very
specific kind of lawsuit
and that's basically it.
That's what it boils down to
but you know it does take some
time if you're looking at it
with your corporate lawyers.
It takes time to get them
comfortable with it.
AUDIENCE: Continuing the lawyer
discussion, can you touch on
how you're dealing with
discovery for legal holds and
also coming from the education
space where we deal with HIPAA
and FERPA a lot and is it
possible or have you already
published a generic thing like
Genentech thinks this is cool
and we're OK with it and
therefore you should feel
less on scared of it?
ADAM GRAFF: I'm not sure
I understood the last
part of your question.
AUDIENCE: Is there just a
general announcement that
Genentech has done this, and
we're fine with that the
implications of going this way?
ADAM GRAFF: Ok, so in terms of
ediscovery and legal holds, we
have implemented a custom
solution for that.
It integrates with our on
premise ediscovery systems, so
because of the API access that
we have through the supervision
API we're able to get people's
mailboxes and then we also have
implemented retention policy
with Gmail so that email is
cleaned at a certain
time period.
There certain labels that you
can apply that will circumvent
the janitoring and there's a
legal hold label and there's a
save type of label that we
use at Genentech as well.
AUDIENCE:
00:49:46,472 --> 00:49:46,468
[INAUDIBLE]
ADAM GRAFF: No we're not.
Go ahead.
What's that?
00:49:56,898 --> 00:49:56,338
Oh, why not Postini?
That's a simple question,
a very complex answer.
We have, at Genentech, we have
a pretty substantial MTA
infrastructure that we use to
handle our mail routing, and
there's a lot of history behind
why we do things a certain way
to keep email within the bounds
of Genentech so to speak.
A lot of it has
to do with that.
The MTA infrastructure
that we've implemented is
kind of a legacy system.
It's got a lot of very complex
routing rules and things that
are there that we weren't
able to port over to
Postini just yet.
AUDIENCE: I wanted to ask all
bit more about the HIPAA piece,
because I'm not sure how much
you're effected by that
or not in your company.
So handling patient data, it
seems to me the biggest issue
is the business associate
agreement that has to happen as
part of the chain from patients
to people managing the middle.
Did you handle that, and how
was your relationship to
Google, in terms of you signing
one and then the next person
of chain of custody,
if you don't mind.
ADAM GRAFF: Sure, so all of our
confidential patient and HIPAA
information is stored in other
systems so it's policy, in
general, within Genentech that
we don't communicate this type
of information across
email to begin with.
It's all held within
certain systems.
Communication is handled from
there, so I don't know if that
answers your question regarding
HIPAA compliance, but that's
how we do its at Genentech.
MIKE O'BRIEN: Any
other questions?
Ok, then I think we're
going to wrap up just
a few minutes early.
Hopefully that was both
interesting and educational.
Maybe it gave you some ideas of
things that you can do within
your company or things you
can do with your customers.
We also invite you to come
visit in the Enterprise
pavilion at Appirio booth.
Thank you very much.